pendant plus de trois heures olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé a
répondu aux questions à des sénateurs
sur sa gestion de la crise du coc vie de
de nombreux sujets ont été passés en
revue la situation au moment de son n
arrivais la communication du
gouvernement le manque de test ou de
masques et puis ces questions en toile
de fond pourquoi la stratégie du
gouvernement a testé tracé isolé at elle
été à dysfonctionnelle a demandé par
exemple l'un des rapporteurs de la
commission
pourquoi ce temps de latence entre le
moment où le gouvernement a été alerté
sur le virus et la mise en application
est des décisions olivier aveyron qui
s'est justifié sur ce point je vous
propose de l'écouter on fait gaffe à
tous quand des masques arrivent de chine
même si vous en manquez sur le
territoire voulait distribuer passer la
douane n'a pas vérifié que les masques
sont conformes et efficace et efficient
et ça prend des jours et ça prend des
jours entre le moment où vous décidez de
quelque chose et le moment où la chose
est opérationnel et efficace
ça prend des jours nous avons un système
particulièrement normatif en france nous
avons fait sauter un paquet de normes
qui était illusoire et dérisoire pendant
la période
ml j'ai signé des décrets d arrêter à
tour de bras pour simplifier les choses
mais que voulez vous il ya des choses
qui prennent du temps je croyais moi je
le regrette
au moins autant aborder aussi à lors de
cette audition le manque d'unité de la
parole publique qui empêche sa
crédibilité c'est en tout cas ce qu'à
pointer du doigt le sénateur des
hauts-de-seine écoutez le au micro de
renault parquet dans une période aussi
anxiogène où par exemple en ce moment on
dit l'épidémie reprend en hospitalise
il ya beaucoup plus de gens real il ya
des morts on ne peut pas continuer à ne
pas avoir une identification sur
quelqu'un qui vient dire presque est
sûre voilà ce qu'on fait voilà qui peut
vous rassurer voilà ce qui peut vous
inquiéter et voilà ce qu'il faut faire
ensemble pour réduire au maximum
l'épidémie on manque de l'unité de
parole de l'unité de commandement dans
cette crise épidémique ou et les
positions qui vient clore les travaux de
cette commission d' enquête du sénat
cette semaine